cuando trabajas con potenciales
estándares de reducción es importante
darse cuenta de que el voltaje es una
propiedad intensiva y para el final del
vídeo entenderás a lo que me refiero con
la palabra intensiva usaremos esta
primera media reacción aquí como ejemplo
esta es la reducción de lyon de plata
plata metálica así que tenemos a gemas
más un electrón nos da plata metálica el
potencial estándar de reducción es de
0.8 volts positivos para esta media
reacción y vamos a empezar calculando el
cambio estándar en la energía libre de
un vídeo anterior sabemos que si tenemos
el voltaje podemos encontrar el cambio
estándar de la energía libre delta g 0
para esta media reacción
eso sería igual a menos recuerda que la
n es el número de moles de electrones y
aquí tenemos un molde electrones tenemos
molt sustituimos eso en la ecuación
luego tenemos
efe
qué es la constante de faraday y de un
vídeo anterior sabemos que es 96.500
coloms sobre mol
es la carga de un molde electrones
tenemos que multiplicar eso por el
voltaje que es 0.80 esto es 0.80 en
lugar de escribir volts escribiré jules
sobre coulón
aquí para poder ver cómo se cancelan las
unidades moles y electrones se cancelan
los colom se cancelan y obtenemos
nuestra respuesta en términos de jules
esto es igual a menos y calculemos
calculamos cuánto es es 1 por 96 500 por
0.8 y debería ser el negativo de eso así
que menos 77 1200 jules lo que debería
decir que es menos 77 kilos jules
obtenemos menos 77 kilo
jules
es el cambio en energía libre que
acompaña a la formación de un molde
plata y qué pasaría si queremos formar
dos moles de plata necesitamos
multiplicar todo en nuestra media
reacción por dos obtenemos 2
y más
dos moles de iones de plata más dos
moles
y electrones nos debería de dar dos
moles de plata sólida
cuál sería el cambio estándar en energía
libre
que acompaña a la formación de dos moles
de plata sólida déjame cambiar colores
aquí si esto es el cambio estándar de
energía libre para la formación de un
molde plata sólida entonces solo
deberíamos de ser capaces de multiplicar
ese número por 2 - 77 kilos jules por 2
nos da menos 154 kilo
gilles ese es el cambio estándar en
energía libre que acompaña la formación
de dos moles de plata la energía libre
es lo que llamamos una propiedad
extensiva depende de con cuánto estás
trabajando estamos trabajando con dos
moles de electrones y la formación de
dos moles de plata por lo tanto tenemos
que cambiar el cambio estándar en la
energía libre
qué sucede con el voltaje tenemos
nuestro cambio estándar de energía libre
usemos esta ecuación otra vez para
calcular el voltaje vamos a sustituir
menos 154 kilos para nuestro cambio
estándar en energía libre y tenemos que
convertirlo en jules eso es menos
154.000 tools y eso es igual a déjame
cambiar colores otra vez aquí esto sería
igual a menos tenemos un signo negativo
y luego ms el número de moles de
electrones ahora estamos diciendo dos
moles de electrones esto sería menos 2
aquí y luego multiplica eso por la
constante de faraday tenemos la
constante de faraday que es
96 500 y luego podemos resolver para el
voltaje podemos resolver para
a 0
calculemos eso nuestra calculadora
tenemos menos 154 mil
tenemos que dividir eso entre -2 y
dividir eso entre -2 y luego dividir eso
entre la constante de faraday 96.500 lo
que nos da un voltaje de 0.80 y redon de
acceso tenemos un voltaje de 0.8 volts
es el mismo voltaje para formar dos
moles de plata que al formar un molde de
plata déjame resaltar eso déjame cambiar
de colores aquí tuvimos un voltaje de
0.8 volts para formar dos moles de plata
y es el mismo voltaje para formar un
molde plata el voltaje es una propiedad
intensiva es lo mismo no importa cuánta
plata estés formando
cuántos moles de electrones uses el
voltaje es el mismo y es importante
recordar eso cuando estás haciendo tu
reducción estándar de potencial es
porque si lo necesitas si necesitas algo
como lo que hicimos aquí
arriba multiplicar la media reacción por
dos no multiplicas el voltaje por dos
porque el voltaje es una propiedad
intensiva